I think what's interesting about this
this book and that's coming out also in
such in a way in proximity to arrival
coming out that the one of the the lead
heroine is a linguist and the you know
that in in both cases in a way that
government helicopters land and say
you're the most important person in the
world right now and I realized that
they're not really they you know they
don't share much other than that but I
think it's it's curious that we have
this and you know one of our projects or
is around linguistics the Rosetta
project where we've been trying to
catalogue all these things and so heroes
that are linguists are important to us
but I'm wondering where where the hero
linguist part of this came from in your
guyses process Neal Neal that was part
of Neal's initial image of it and she
has to be the hero linguist in order for
the story to work I was delighted to be
given that as a character whose voice
could evolve she anything that I would
say about like why that might be
happening why there's the rise of like
the kick-ass female linguist would be
specious and you know superficial so I
won't go there away with it
I mean clearly like we're in a world
where the more we communicate the more
distant we've you know the usual tropes
did I answer your question no I did I
just find it interesting that yeah that
we have that now it's great to get to
know female linguist our historical
linguists are they are the heroes I'm
not action movies I'm not a linguist but
I was a nerdy enough kid involving
language that when I was a kid like I
would read nerdy like books about where
language comes from and I don't think I
made as much use of it as I would have
liked to but there's little places where
the fact that I know a little bit about
little bits of language kind of work
their way in and given the opportunity
I'd certainly do more of that well you
should mention the reader of the
audiobook oh yes so um
small world Department the my college
roommate and best friend was a Harvard
linguistics major and the character in
the book is a Harvard linguistics made
and after being a linguistics major she
went on to become an actress and a
voice-over artist and she is voicing the
Harvard linguistics major so I'm very
happy and she sounds great so that's
awesome
[Music]
you